hey guys how's it going so I haven't
actually posted my official thoughts on
scene Deadpool the movie I was like last
week right yes the movie was so so good
I don't know much about Deadpool
character but obviously like I like Ryan
Reynolds I love Marvel movies and it was
originally supposed to be only clips
wait I have to get the light shoots we
gotta go back so for this fan event we
thought that we were only gonna be
seeing clips from the movie that I
haven't been seen before but they end up
showing the entire film TJ was there and
Stanley was there they had like a bunch
of the cast they had the director it was
so incredible I can't wait so it comes
out cuz I'm gonna see it again this is
not sponsored this is pure actual
genuine love for the film I'll go see on
Valentine's Day we could Buick yeah it's
right now I'm going to a Lighting Store
I have such an affinity for this light
that I am about to get replaced when I
moved to California right before I moved
my dad replaced the bulb so that was
probably 2007
maybe beginning in 2007 and it just
burned out and this is the light that I
use quite often when I'm not using my
like the LED lights so now almost 10
years later I'm getting this light bulb
replaced and I actually got this light
from my old job that I used to work at
you want to tell me how you got the
light if you guys read my book you'll
know about the chiropractor who was mean
to me basically what I put the job he
was like
you're worthless you're never gonna find
with a job and I was so upset I cried it
was lumps we shirt waiting where's place
that I've ever he's in jail is he really
what so I think he might officially be
as well I open up my trunk after I quit
after he'd made me feel like a big
worthless loser I was like oh there's
still a light in here from one of the
shoots so I had no job I had no money
had absolutely nothing and this light
was the start of my YouTube making
career and here we are actually we're
almost 11 years later because I started
working there but way before actually
2005-2006 this light it is a part of me
this light means so much to me but if
this light turns out to be broken what
am I gonna do how did he so sad it was
an accidental feat the light has been
fixed I cannot reiterate how much this
light means to me and what a stepping
stone in my life this stupid silly light
signifies for me and the fact that it's
fixed I'm so happy the only problem is
it's a 500 watt bulb they didn't have a
750 and we didn't want to go to the
thousand because it's already a very
very hot light so I got very you think
it did either way I got the light
everything is awesome and now we gotta
cross the street
myun did you fix that and it's straight
oh how did you fix it I took it all
apart and put it back together that's
really fun excels like man I really need
a handyman guess i didn'ti the handyman
needed a handy Jana I keep it has not
worked in ever straight Manny what do
you think of this just exciting look at
you my little prince how's it going so
we had a interesting day today huh
breakfast I made a cooking video right
here I made churros and I'm just gonna
tell you that when you guys see this
video I don't want any judgment so
please make zero judgment because what I
did was not good so we'll just say
you're just gonna have to wait and see
the video because it's it might be one
of the worst things that I've ever done
we're gonna go to Matt's house we're
gonna play Monopoly and maybe go to
dinner and I'm vlogging on a new cameras
I'm not sure you can tell have an
unboxing review also soon I plan on
doing one of all of the cameras the
vlogging cameras that I've been using
because there's things that I like about
each one and things that I don't like
about each one that you might like for
different situations I don't know anyway
I gotta go cuz Jenna's in the car and
the dog that's ready to roll hey baby
boy baby boy where you at there you are
ah see cute
[Music]
now do you want to be kissing your lips
Maddie you ready to go to Matt's house
you need to go to Matt's house
Matt hey you're Matt he's mad
you're both max oh he knows that he
knows we're here try to focus on you
where we are there's edge that's
mirrorless it's like a DSLR but like not
can I see it yeah focus on you look at
the dog he's taking a lot of fun of
focus can i play with toy does this
screen come out recording why doesn't it
look that good on the screen wow this
doesn't seem like a pretty I would love
to see this on the computer
Maddie come here baby boy we'll see you
guys when I get to dinner feel like it
doesn't look completely focused
this is a new camera
[Music]
Cole great video this is some really
great content really great concept
[Applause]
incredible of wine well get a color
that's gonna go with next season here no
we just wanted wine and a wine opener
and we're here next season at Suns blue
yeah what are we gonna get
what kind of should we get here I'm just
trying to camera great great choice I
need to know extreme
are you sure cuz I also see blue here
stupid you busy
I'm not trying to lose a tooth and
return it some fun
wait that's all I need
Jeff you made no selections wait what's
lineups what wasn't lineups
one of you should get those set yeah
it's like nerds rope well that's on the
ground
do we want
[Music]
look at this this is a wild game of
Monopoly
where's my gun I was so far I have one
property right why you know work well
playing Fallout 4 Monopoly ready one use
buy property yeah you just got a
property
oh wow there is really wild deeds
already there you go
Maddy's having a great day I want to eat
we're using Maddy's cage as a coffee
table actually works quite well
oh all right
flavor Santa Fe let's show this
centipede
hmm looks nice cool
[Music]
good work Matt good work you so here's
me you know nothing okay I'm sorry I hit
the Lord and everything just fell
why don't you hit the board you were
frustrated cuz athletes getting skipped
yeah it is really frustrating meeting
skip just restarted yours
Judas you're a liar it's been your turn
about you not the days over
when you were like I don't even know
where my pieces that's right here here
and now you're here
get ready focus on this it's not
focusing focus on this did I get a piece
you got this travel to go collect your
dollars sounds good thank you have a
great time you have you only pretty much
everything on the board
what so really who won the game yeah
well let me get the three part if
three-party wasn't involved I would loss
[Music]
we've got some really delicious 7-eleven
honey wheat pretzels all this for even
awfully no I see why don't you make a
new updated what's on my iPhone
and I said you know what that's a great
idea walk downstairs brush my hair
Jenna's making breakfast and here we are
making the video